και λαρώτες αλήθκες και τούτες συαλήθειες που λέο είναι πικρές γιατί είναι κάτι το οποίον
δστυχώς ε μπορε να το καταλάβει ο κυπρέως δδεν μπορεί μέ τοντίενέημας υπάρχει η λέξι
αυτό καταστροφι που των καιρό του μααρίου και πάει και πει και πάε και οπάδυστυχώς
και οπότε τους έλεα οπότε ελέω αλλά τόσα τολαλλάσσουμε θέματα γσεσχίσωπότε σα φύγο να κάνειε
εσύ το αι να φτάζουμ πάει στων ολυμπιακόν λα λύσείσε με το απόέλσήμερα έχεις ρκε
τους φίλου ταποέλνομίζωένας που τίλοσε κιο πρόδρο ένα ναλάβανες ποττ αποσήμερα ίνανήμομόνο νμου με το
αποέλ μόπου τους φανατιγούς τ απόευκέέναμε μούν εγώ το ότε ο πετρίς οπηλάδος ο πάμπος
οχιλάς ο πατρίδας αστουν πουτούτι ποδαπου εμπαίρναμε μπροστά και πέζαμε ξήλο μεστα γήπεδα πρ πετάμνουμε
κι ιέφρτώαίωυκια να πα τους προβολίς τούμε αγιούμακατόαι αλάτε σημέκιυ πάνω α καταλάβεις ημών μετά
εφει πία στη ρουμανα τά ας πούμε ας οπό την αλήθεια εν θα θενα να
ξανα να κατωθώ μετες μάες με στην κύπρωτιότι δυστυχώς είναι βρομια και δυσοδία όπως είναι
σήμερα με το μοντέλλω το ημμερινώ τώρα νβρεθεέας πρώδρο τεις δημοκρατία άτα τότα πράγματα γιατί
δυστυχς των το πράγμα ξεκινά και φτάνει διαδή μόνο νααν έναπροεδρος αποφασιστιός πουέννα φατσίζω κτω
του κάτω και να τασάσει ούλα να πούμε ροότε έχουμε ποτός φορος στην κύπρο ιότι
εν παίζεται το ποδόσφέρο μέσα στα γύπεδαα καταλάβει σε μέρα τον δεγάτο επί α των
εμπαγό με άλλα μιαά πίμε σκοπό να διδάξο τους πέκτες και να δείξω στην πράξι
τα τα πράματα που γάμνο μετα με το μιαλώ δα έα πακτι που πέει ι
δύο να το βάα πες γι κώ καμε έν πάκαι τε ένα ν εκατο μήνων
ευρω και πέταρνα τηπόνι αντο π νπήγα εξάδανε πίατελικών κυπέλλου και είχα και τη διατήσ
έναντιώμαλός παθμο κακουργήματος πα των τελιγών στίσα που ότε και στον τελιό που ται την
επόμενη χρόνια